you have a trivia question for me for
the goats in a bad way for the
championship
yep all right it's kind of a tough one
you can get this i might have to help
you a little here but it's january 26
today as you know which team has lost
two super bowls
on this date in the same
stadium okay so on this date
in the same stadium i'll i'll help you
out a little bit here wait wait
okay no you don't want me out all right
help me out um
wow okay give me a hint okay i'll say
it's the new orleans it's in new orleans
okay so that's well it wasn't it's it's
not the vikings first of all back in
those days the super bowl wasn't played
this late
so it can't be that so it would be the
super dome
and wow
no no no no it's the patriots it is the
patriots correct
to the bears in super bowl 20 and to the
packers in super bowl 31 yep correct
correct correct that's pretty and then
they
run their first super bowl there i know
right isn't that isn't that amazing how
that works out that way just a few years
later they win their first super bowl at
that place but uh yeah
ironic don't you think go ahead i'm not
sure i don't use ironic anymore because
i never know
what the hell when in doubt i used to i
love it properly
all right goat of the day man there are
too many to choose from
um i gotta go with mike patton man for
the call that was the dagger yeah
and and the packers did a good job of
trying to remove the dagger
and put the dagger into the buccaneers
and there are other goats responsible
for keeping that from happening
but the initial dagger that hobbled the
packers came courtesy of the ridiculous
defense that was called by mike patton
we broke it down earlier it's inside
leverage allowing
the receiver to catch the ball and get
out of bounds or run right by you as
scottie miller did
and score a touchdown and it's 21-10 at
the half when it
could have been uh it still could have
been 1410 or at worst 1710.
yeah uh agreed i mean that was that was
definitely the first pick uh i mean
all right let me get away from that game
i'll go to the other one i'll i'll give
sean mcdermott
you know goats in the bad way you know
for for
the field goal thing and and and and
again
you know i can understand the first one
it's 21-9
it's the end of the first half let's
just get some points feel good going to
halftime keep them having to play
let's keep this game competitive all
that but the second one
you know now you've seen kansas city go
down the field again you got to go wait
we haven't really stopped them all day
and now it's 24 to 12. that's the one
where i go
hey you're playing patrick mahomes in
kansas city and andy reid
in kansas city field goals ain't gonna
get it done today
that was you know like kissing your
sister that one there that made no sense
did nothing for their football team it
just helped them go down by 16.
i mean really so that one to me for the
scope of the game
knowing who you're playing against to go
and take uh the field goal and still
be down by nine that made no sense to me
i remember week three ravens chiefs
monday night ravens have a great drive
right out of the gates and instead of
going forward on fourth and goal they
kick the field goal it's like that's not
how you beat the chiefs yeah you beat
the chiefs with touchdowns
field goals are just going to uh uh
make it inevitable that they are going
to roll right past you i'm going back to
green bay the goats are grazing in green
bay matt lafleur
robbing us all of what would have been a
memorable moment i got somebody emailing
me during the show saying oh can you
imagine how bad leflore would have been
killed if he had gone for it there and
not gotten
he wouldn't have been killed at all he
would have been killed
right that's what everybody thought he
was gonna do that's what aaron rodgers
thought he was gonna do
that's what you do in that moment the
seizing is a season is riding on it and
if you don't make it
the buccaneers have the ball on their
eight you've got three timeouts you've
got the two minute warning
and uh maybe they'll be more
conservative as you said earlier in
their play calling
pinned against their their own goal line
so i i i
and all sorts of stuff could have
happened you know leflore said well
yeah you know we we kicked off and you
know they had the pi call well yeah
there could have been a pi call on them
if you had gone for it a bunch of
different things could have happened
maybe you could have gotten first and
goal at the one
and you could have milked more time off
the clock if there's pass interference
in the end zone we don't know what would
happen because
we were robbed at that moment so matt
laflore sorry great coach but that day
uh go in a bad way yeah definitely i
know i didn't want to go back to lefleur
right after you went petting i wanted to
take him
really but i went to mcdermott just to
change the game up but um
all right so you got the two best picks
in the draft so far here we go
i'll go aaron jones as the next one
man you know you talked about mike
pettin and those issues
those probably the biggest play in the
game second biggest play in the game is
the first third down
of the second half you know aaron jones
running a crossing route
catches the ball four
four maybe five steps gets a chance to
tuck it up
field and jermaine whitehead just you
know clobbers him
and and loses the ball for the second
time with the second
type of hit from the same guy but that
was a huge moment in the game again
yes we know the touchdown made it 21-10
so what 11 before the half it's 21-10
it's aaron rodgers you know they can go
down it's 21-17
whoop-dee-doo but now all right whoa you
fumble and they got the ball at the
eight yard line now it's 28-10
that's a whole different ball game
altogether and now it's like
you got to play perfect for the rest of
the half and probably need the other
team to mess up once or twice
so uh that was a huge moment in the
football game aaron jones goat in a bad
way
are you saying jermaine whitehead i
might have said that yeah you know what
i think
jermaine there may be a jermaine there
was a jermaine whitehead i'm sorry
jordan whitehead
jordan jordan whitehead is the guy
that's i'm sorry jordan
i'm sorry i'm sorry about that yes i
i've got to go
to the chiefs bills game for my last one
and you know when you look at the things
the bills need for the future
they've got their jim kelly they've got
their andre reid now it's time to go get
their thurman thomas
because devin singletary t.j yeldon did
not get it done and i don't know if zack
moss would have made much of a
difference but my god nine carries for
32 yards combined
combined now at a certain point you got
to say well maybe brian dayball should
have committed to the run but if you
know you guys aren't going to run if
they're not getting it done in the run
why do you want to go from first and 10
to second and 11. why do you i mean
if you know it's not there why are you
going to keep banging your head against
the wall they need somebody
on that offense in the backfield that
can complement
josh allen and when when the passing
game is what it now is for the bills it
shouldn't be all that hard to find a
running back
who can get it done and really take that
offense to the next level chris
no i agree that's that's uh they're so
close
they need a running back a top they need
just a running game in general but
you're right they need a real
you know go-to running back bell cow we
can depend on him
and they get one more weapon on the
outside and you just go whoa
they could hit the you know we can't
stop them we can't defend them type of
mode
as far as what they can do on that side
of the ball but that that was apparent
they need that
uh and they need that one other player
on both sides of the ball i think we
discussed that yesterday a little bit
that has to happen um all right my last
one
i mean i i easily could pick
uh i could easily pick tom brady but i'm
not gonna
i'm not he did he did win they're going
to the super bowl
as as bad as in if he is that third and
fourth quarter were
i think i'm gonna go to the green bay
packers offensive line that's just where
i'm gonna go
we talked about it all year we talked
about her a lot towards the end of
november
into december wow look at they've turned
the corner
they've become one of the best offensive
lines in football you know you heard me
say a number of times like man they're
getting to the point where they can kind
of just run on anybody
but they couldn't do it against this
team this week the buccaneer showed that
they're their kryptonite
and not only in the run game and just
snuffing that out but the tackles
especially
i mean billy turner remembers at right
tackle there
uh they just got abused at times as far
as just
absolutely steamrolled run over that way
and that was a big part of the game
altogether
uh ricky wagner not remembers i'm sorry
i'm getting my chiefs and packers guys
messed up
and it really was stunning to see it as
good as the offensive line had been
against the rams to just go the other
way and we saw it early
like first drive yeah you knew it was
good gobbled up it's like here we go
that's not supposed to be happening
not good for the packers but uh hey they
as aaron rodgers said
they had their chances even after they
were down 18 they had their chances
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports